all right so last week we played what
could be
the la dodger's new theme courtesy of
our very own nathan
tannenbaum esquire he rewrote the lyrics
to the 70s hit song
spooky spooky named it after la dodger
superstar
mookie bass yeah so the host of the
post-game radio show for the dodgers
played a little snippet of it last week
after
one of the dodgers wins against the
braves got a little musical snack for
you in case you missed it
[Music]
all right so huge thanks to cledo
escobado for
doing that for me i sent him the lyrics
he's a huge dodger fan he said be happy
to do it
i don't know if it was good luck for the
dodgers but they won
last night it was a dramatic game seven
and the dodgers are moving on to the
world series
so the man the myth the legend the
song's about smokey bets there it is
that's why he's a superstar made a
leaping catch at the wall in the fifth
inning to stop the braves from scoring a
home run so
the dodgers won the game and the series
4-3 taking on the tampa bay ray starting
tomorrow night john
i'm just saying if this is one way to
get the dodgers ahead writing music
clayton kershaw's next on your agenda we
gotta find one we can do it i'll work on
it cbs this morning's next we'll see you
tomorrow morning